depuis mars dernier à l'étrange
professeur a fait son apparition sur le
devant de la scène médiatique
il s'agit bien entendu de didier rahout
épidémiologiste renommé du centre de
recherches de marseille et a défendu
durant des mois le fait que la
chloroquine permettait de combattre la
cobi 19 l'atlantique sur les gros d'un
virus très vite contredit par de
nombreux spécialistes la france est
alors divisé en deux camps et pour les
internautes nul doute que le reportage
enquête exclusive qui lui était
consacrée hier soir sur m6 était fait
part des opposants aux professeurs les
journalistes du programme n'ont pas
hésité à écorner l'image de didier
rahout notamment au sujet des
financements de ces recherches
les hôpitaux de marseille percevrait
plus de 10 millions d'euros chaque année
du ministère de la santé
s'il n'a pas souhaité répondre aux
questions des équipes de l'émission ces
derniers ne se sont pas privés pour dire
ce qu'il pensait du personnage c'est un
système mais management basé pour les
internautes il ne fait aucun doute que
les équipes d'enquêté exclusive ont
réalisé un reportage à charge sur le
professeur pour d'autres m6 a bien fait
son travail
alors l'émission enquête exclusive sur
le professeur raoul et d'etel trop à
charge
son avocat fabrice di vizio était avec
nous en plateau pour en parler
vous êtes très très très nombreux à
écrire aussi sur les réseaux vous
attendez les réponses de fabrice di
vizio et on va revoir toutes les toutes
les toiles à tout ce qui s'est passé
hier et tout ce qui a été à charge
contre eaunes le professeur raoult
merci d'elana maître fabrice di vizio
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
vous êtes l'avocat didier raoult et
c'est vrai que hier ça a été la fête de
didier raoult sur m6 ça a été vous
attendiez à un tel pugilat ouais
vraiment oui ouais vous aviez eu écho de
cette enquête non mais vous savez allier
normal c'est normal moi je pense qu'il
manque un truc dans l'histoire c'est
quoi l'assassinât de kennedy
voilà pour veiller well as eu à un
moment donné on en est contre nous on
est là il ya plus qu'un truc à faire
c'est effectivement accusé en outre
d'avoir tué kennedy
il n'en parle plus comme ça c'est vrai
les rires ont accusé de tous les maux
hier n'ont pas de kennedy justement oui
ça c'est le seul truc c'est une vallée
vanne là ça le fait marrer bon sur ce
qu'ils ont dit oui il va répondre à ces
quelques questions sur sa jeune homme
est ce que tu voulais comme un truc
juste un mot ça veut dire ce qui peut
être convaincu par sa mère franchement
pas demandeur téléspectateurs justement
monsieur sachs a vaincu après oui mais
en remettre aux divisions va revenir
point par point
déjà première chose raoult le
manipulateur
alors certains de ses collaborateurs ont
témoigné à visage masqué et en forme
bien qu'ils arrêtent les études quand il
veut et que le professeur manipule des
chiffres ce sont des accusations très
graves et hier qui ont été émises sur m6
contre le professeur à ou regarder qu'on
fait chez didier raoult le temps général
c'est ce que didier rahout vous qu'on
fasse
donc à c'est lui qui a les cités ci lui
propose les thématiques
c'est lui qui dit à quoi ça doit aboutir
et si on aboutit pas à ça c'est qu'on a
mal travaillé
et donc il faut recommencer jusqu'à ce
qu'on aboutisse ce qui est extrêmement
dangereux évidemment en termes de chance
il est arrivé qu'une nouvelle dise en
face c'est pas grave que ce soit font ce
qu'ils pensent cependant que moi mais
alors fabrice di vizio déjà là dessus je
sais pas si on interrogeait vos
collaborateurs il dirait quoi sur vous
abm fracasserait bon alors mois pour des
agressions on prête des flec
welch que j'ai passé les gens à 10 h
voilà combien y'a quelqu'un disait japon
air on sait pas qui ils sont on sait pas
dans quel contexte manifestement ils
bossent plus avec lui
manifestement ils sont pas contents je
vous dis moi interrogé mes anciens
collaborateurs vous avez parce que j'ai
pris sur moi mais moi interrogé mes
anciens collaborateurs vous allez voir
aussi bas c'est bon moi j'ai lu encore
un article aussi la semaine dernière qui
me concerne et ya toujours un
collaborateur mais c'est qui au
laboratoire pour approche mais c'est pas
ça c'est un mec comme damien croisé une
fois j'étais moi n'est pas qui vous êtes
non meilleurs ce qui m'étonne c'est que
effectivement si ce qu'ils disent est
vrai là il ya des autorités sanitaires
quoi qu'est-ce qu'ils ont attendu pour
balancer des plateaux de topcider raul a
expliqué essam l'histoire est ainsi que
je le sais qu'à une plainte de balancer
conclura août a été classé sans suite
alors on allait réagir après parce que
je vais montrer les extraits voulez vous
dire si c'est trop pas charge ou pas et
je veux avoir aussi l'avis des
téléspectateurs gardez bien vos petites
pancartes
voilà isabelle dit non c'est normal
c'était sur un site mais on peut la
comprendre oui benjamin castaldi veut
retourner au jeu dira ou manipulent t-il
ses études
les équipes d'enquêté qui vont
rencontrer fritz rosendaël c'est un
épidémiologiste et néerlandais avec qui
j'ai travaillé longuement de renommée
mondiale et il démontre que le
professeur a ou manipulent les études en
arrêtant les mesures quand il le
souhaite alors lui il pas et parlent à
visage découvert toiles à l'huile sur la
demande officielle d'essai clinique de
didier raoul tu il est prévu de tester
les patients le septième jour
mais dans l'étude publiée les tests
s'arrête le sixième jour pourquoi tu il
regardait le jour si c'est pas le jour
cette année
peut-être parce que les résultats
étaient meilleurs le jour si ce que le
jour cette année devant tsonga et ça si
vous écrivez les règles vous devez les
suivre forum et ce n'est pas ce qu'ils
ont fait alors oui des vidéos avocats du
professeur ou lui parle à visage
découvert mais d'accord mais je veux
dire il ya un problème déjà de base
c'est qu'en fait on n'arrête pas de
parler du protocole raul tant qu vide
mais moussa seydi ça vous dit quelque
chose c'est le chef des seychelles
maladies infectieuses dakar oui le mec
c'est le mec c'est ebola quoi les mecs
il est venu dire il m'a écrit pour dire
écoutez moi je vais venir à l'audience
la témoigner pierre borios ni infections
à milan et les mecs vous dis moi je les
utilise et chats vous en avez combien
effectivement riches
hervé riches parce que je veux c'est
qu'on me parle d'un mec là on me parle
d'un truc on me faisant rien mais vous
auriez aimé qu'ils aient d'autres des
noms c'est à dire que moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse à reportage sur le comité
sur la chloroquine mère allons jusqu'au
bout du truc quoi c'est safricas
comprend une étude on dit bravo tu n'as
bidonné merci la vie donnée comment
j'explique que moi j'ai reçu j'ai compté
à mes équipes ont compté depuis chaque
cadre out 1352 mail de médecins mal
médecins du monde entier qui disent moi
je vais utiliser le protocole 1
et ça marche alors oui on va venir
effectivement témoigner à l'audience en
faire quoi tous les collaborateurs alors
deuxième truc raoult le tyran tous les
collaborateurs du professeur ou
apparemment ils ont été voir benjamin
castaldi ont témoigné dans le reportage
et l'on perd visage masqué parce que
selon eux didier raoult n'hésiterait pas
à arrêter des carrières il se confie sur
les méthodes de management du professeur
à ou qui aurait des méthodes de tyrans
vous allez bientôt écrire un livre sur
lui donc astana a dit
clairement capables d'arrêter des
carrières il est clairement capables
d'empêcher des mutations nous les
étudiants en tout cas on vivait dans une
espèce de climat de peur constant on
avait peur de présenter nos résultats
parce qu'on savait qu'on allait se faire
une fois sur deux aboyer dessus et
traiter d'idiot et traités
d'incompétents
c'est un système mais moi ma chouette
qui est basée sur la peur et l'on rit
tarissement absolue alors fabrice di
vizio
je réponds bah bravo quand les mecs
effectivement se découvriront et qu'ils
auront des faits concrets à des dates
précises et bah enfin peut-être peut
commencer à en parler mais les types qui
viennent témoigner à visage couvert sur
un système de management moi je sais pas
ce que c'est maintenant didier didier
raoult est ce qu est ce qui vous a
presque ce qui vous a donné son avis sur
ce reportage qui a été fait hier il s'en
fout totalement complètement
complètement vraiment plus vraiment il
n'a pas l'impression que tout le monde
lui tombe dessus en ce moment il s'en
fout complètement
on s'en fout complètement pas vraiment
bah c'est un mec qui bosse quoi c'est un
chercheur ibos et aurait ça n'intéresse
pas il fait de la médecine
l'homo de patients qui l'a soigné ali a
chu depuis mars
1 parce que bon je veux juste te dire un
truc là rama yade c'est que y'a plein de
trucs
or chloroquine que raul se faisait au
mois de mars et on le galet dessus alors
qu'aujourd'hui has les a repris quand
même un mal si j'ai une thérapie je te
montre raoult le charlatan c'était un
autre volet du reportage de m6 hier soir
quelques semaines avant que le
professeur roux se fasse accusé de
charlatanisme par l'ordre des médecins
les enquêtes de les équipes d'enquêté
qui suivent ont rencontré un
infectiologue du spin off de vue qui
sous-entend que les plus hauts débits
peuvent être dangereux regarder il est
reproché au professeur marseillais
de ne pas avoir été assez prudent de
mépriser l'intérêt général et enfin
d'avoir une attitude qui pourrait
relever du charlatanisme
on a détecté des graves manquements à la
déontologie médicale en aient signalé je
pense pas que l'ordre des médecins
puissent dire mais non circulez ya rien
à voir
c'est des vrais manquement à la
déontologie donc il va falloir qu'ils
statuent ce qui nous a motivés nous
c'est d'essayer d'arrêter cette
communication pour coller mais les
patients arrêtent de recevoir ce
traitement inutile et potentiellement
des terrasses à la dernière partie
l'émission parce que je veux votre avis
là-dessus à vous et à vous autour de la
table c'est parti alors juste vous dites
non vraie joie
moi je dis non alors c'est vrai qu'avec
quelques week-ends trop loin avec tout
ça je trouve qu'il ya quelques termes
comme il a sorti de son chapeau des
j'aime bien relever les d'outreau
expression au passage mais j'aime bien
regarder attentivement les 58 minutes ne
s'étaient pas cher non je trouvais que
c'était relativement factuel il ya les
adorateurs de raout de danse si jésus
torah ou je m'en fous moi draw
mais moi j'ai un mari qui est un
adorateur de raul donc chaque fois il ya
des débats la maison il m'a obligé à
isabelle la questure et un résumé de
tout ce qui a été dit depuis un an et
demi quand mais sur rail n'ont jamais
vous avez un autre extrait fabrice di
vizio vous vous l'avez trouvé comment le
reportage dit la vérité il acharné
redick merci à vous merci non mais vous
savez moi g messieurs c'est pas à charge
ou pas à charge c'est pas un portable ça
non je dirais pas ça c'est quoi ça c'est
pas de manquer d'avoir été les conneries
je ne sais pas une enquête une enquête
de police qui craint que quelqu'un comme
ça ça crée des mecs en taule pour rien
quoi je sais pas une enquête çà çà c'est
géré avec par exemple ce qu'ils veulent
mais parce qu'il faut vendre le
professeur ou fait vendre mais bien sur
quoi ou le fait vendre des montres est
généralement très je vous transmets
jackson et fait vendre
si le prêt si le professeur raoult était
un charlatan comme la firme comme ils
l'affirment dans le reportage ou
serait-il tout ça pour l'argent
discussions demander à un moment dans l'
enquête après avoir affirmé que ces
études n'étaient pas sérieuses le
reportage a démontré que plus les
chercheurs publiés des études plus ça
rapporte de l'argent
regardez il en france plus un
scientifique publiée
plus il obtient de financement pour ses
recherches chaque article publié donne
droit à un nombre de points en fonction
de la notoriété de la revue ainsi grâce
aux milliers de publications de lier
achu les hôpitaux de marseille dont des
banlieues a chu percevrait plus de 10
millions d'euros chaque année
en 2017 un rapport du haut conseil de
l'évaluation de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur est très sévère
sur les pratiques de l'ia chu
l'accent devrait être mis davantage sur
la qualité des publications et pas sur
le volume de publication de mauvaise
qualité
alors raymond me disais un truc il a
chronométré
il a regardé trois comme en 40 minutes
en garde avant l'ordi assure le redis je
regardais et à six émissions
commençaient à 23h20 la famille attend
de mimizan 42 minutes
c'est en train de dormir a fallu
attendre quarante deux minutes pour
avoir un semblant de gens qui allaient
dans le sens pour avoir douste-blazy
estrosi qui vantait la chloroquine donc
ça fait ça fait quand même long 42
minutes et tout de suite derrière il ya
un mec qui intervient ça du risque de
muter un mec qui intervient pour dire
que raout il en joue justement de la
thèse du complot
ce truc là ce truc qui s'est passé sur
m6 hier je regrette genre préféré qu'il
fasse dix minutes et après parce que moi
j'ai l'impression que moi si je vais sur
facebook pour des contre enquêtes comme
ça quand même la théorie du complot
je veux trouver 10 des émissions comme
ça qu'ils disent la même chose mais sur
a ou le contraire en fait qui vante le
professeur ou alors là à breezy visio il
fait ça pour l'argent quand il ya vous
répondre ça marrant de dire qu'il fait
ça pour l'argent
alors que quand même on a balancé un
traitement qu'elle rime d'hygiène qui
coûtent une fortune dont tout le monde
sait qui marchait pas en novembre tout
le monde savait qu'ils marchaient pas
tout le monde
et pourtant il a continué d'être balancé
à l'assistance publique donc on peut
quand même se demander qui fait de
l'argent gilead qui est quand même une
entreprise donc le peuple en marche pas
c'est notoire ça marche ça elle a un
chiffre d'affaires qui a explosé fabrice
di vizio des tiges d'une bêtise faire de
l'argent je vais répondre à la place du
professeur anglais jusque là je vais me
faire l'avocat du professeur d'art ou là
dessus de ce que je sais après voilà moi
je vous dira le professeur à où il a eu
des propositions énorme dans tous les
sens une évidence vraiment avec beaucoup
beaucoup plus d'argent que ce qu'ils
gagnent actuellement je joue lui sinon
mais voilà il faut le dire non méritants
des messieurs si vous voulez faire de
l'argent il faut pas être fonctionnaire
si vous voulez faire de l'argent il faut
pas être à la tête d'année achu faut pas
être hospitalier faut être honnête vous
faut être ou alors faire des
accointances avec les labos avec des
gros conflits d'intérêts et à les
regarder les conflits d'intérêts de raul
t on en reparle
et les regards des conflits d'intérêts
des mecs ils le déglingué on en reparle
vous n'êtes pas des ripoux d'argent la
bannière coiffe pour envoyer valdinguer
dire qu'en france c'est une obligation
de déclaration d'intérêts quand tu
passes à la télé et que concrètement ce
que j'observe hier soir c'est que perd
tout le monde a oublié de dire combien
il touche à des labos c'est tout c'est
tout de même la hollande elle même lol
surtout nous landais d'alliora mais moi
je me suis renseigné j'ai regardé alors
prendre la monnaie mais il prend de la
monnaie si les labos le hollandais
accord donc moi au début je me suis dit
vite on vous dit quoi que dise tiens oui
et 1 et un lobbying des rambo évidemment
pour en être vraiment sûrs qu'un lobby
les labos c'est une évidence très même
il ya un truc si mais qui prend la tête
dans ce truc là c'est que raul
on peut pas le lâcher cinq minutes ça y
est il est poursuivi devant l'ordre ok
je vais le déférer les poursuit dans la
chambre ok ça y est ça se fait ça
charlatans et ben la chambre décidera
s'il s'acharne à temps alors ça sert à
quoi tient le reportage
je vais vous montrer un autre extrait
elle chez hbo à 20h50 en direct vous
allez voir c'est le témoignage de cette
collaboratrice de liée à celle qui
affirme qu'elle n'a même pas confiance
en son propre diplômes parce qu'il y
aurait beaucoup de falsifications ont
leur vie sain j'ai le sentiment quelque
part d'avoir usurpé
mon diplôme ne pas mériter mon diplôme
je peux pas mériter mon diplôme ou dans
ces conditions là j'ai pas réellement
fait de la recherche pendant quatre ans
c'est pas vrai et
et c'est super dur de se dire que ce
qu'on a fait ça vaut vraiment pas grand
chose on s'est alors dit ravi de vous
dit non
nicolas émission elle a été à la hauteur
de ma démission et et de ma désillusion
moi j'étais la première sur ce plateau à
défendre le professeur à ou alors non
pas en tant que scientifique parce que
je n'y connais rien mais c'est vrai que
quand il a commencé à prendre la parole
en mars
pour moi ça a été une sorte de bouffée
d'espoir au fond du tunnel miser mais
oui en fait c'est l'homme providentiel
en fait donc j'ai cru ça a été pour moi
une sorte de gourou de messi en tout cas
de grands professeurs reconnus avec un
cv long comme le bras
et donc j'ai cru est effectivement force
est de constater que moi je m'en fous
qu'il soit tirant pas tyran mégalomane
égal au miso giroud pas misogyne j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] moi je veux que ce soit
juste un grand professeur qui fasse
avancer
effectivement la recherche est
effectivement force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui le bilan me semble-t-il
mais entend moi je ne suis pas
scientifique me semble catastrophique
comment vous avez vu il a dit que ça
ferait au moins - de le reconnaître aux
donneurs d'ordres m'attendais célèbre
attendez attendez moi par les jeunes
absents que ça fait plus de morts quand
même un million et demi au jour j
attends des jeux cultes il a dit qu'ils
auraient pas deuxième vague on en est à
la troisième vague je suis pas d'accord
du tout avec ça alors attendez je
termine après vous allez venir parce que
vous êtes bien plus spécial excellent du
russe saisonniers aussi oui c'est
pourquoi c'est pas le cas banon et ça
vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé mais
évidemment que si sa vue saisonnier est
d'ailleurs effectivement vous regardez
un petit peu ce qui se dit aujourd'hui
notamment au japon où on commence à vous
expliquer je faisais ça ce matin dans
une revue scientifique où on vous disait
que bon quand même là il faut être clair
sur le fait que quand les beaux jours
vont revenir on a un peu d'espoir là
parce que du coup va y avoir une baisse
on est de la charge du virus quoi et
année ce qui s'est passé au printemps et
en été ça je dis rien mais ce n'est pas
parce que les joailliers bon
non mais vide manque 6 au caractère
saisonnier traqués qu'ils fassent un
abandonné notoirement si vous voulez
rien ménagé pour comme un argument un
point si vous voulez on vous dit c'est
la catastrophe
mais vers si on fait le compte à
supposer admis qu'ils soient trompés sur
ce que vous voulez mais on fait le
compte de tous ceux qui sont trompés
dans cette crise
je veux dire ce qui dérange c'est ce que
une fois professeur raoult a pu dire je
me suis un peu trompé ce qu'il a dit là
dit il l'a dit plusieurs fois il ya
surtout desjardins inc effectivement
prêt au cas où tu sais que il a dit que
lui ne vit pas dans l'avenir n'a pas de
boule de cristal il a dit ça il a dit
qu'il était pas nostradamus
mais voilà alors bien jouer et montrer
un autre extrait ya quand même un
extrait et deux extraits à décharge
dans le reportage exemple avec le
témoignage de stéphane qui affirme qu'il
a été guérie grâce aux terrains
traitement du professeur à ou regardez
je suis obligé de l'avouer de dire voilà
à peu près 24 24 36 heures après je
respirais comme si j'étais dans les
alpes je prends vraiment cet exemple moi
je me dis que le traitement a fait
gagner 8 10 jours où tout aurait pu
dégénérer donc je remercie le professeur
raoul voilà tout simplement
on ne peut pas dire à didier raoul tu
dois suivre la réglementation parce que
c'est lui qui fait la réglementation
quand dans un hôpital de guerre ça pisse
le sang partout on fait ce qu'on peut
en fait et c'est ce qu'il a fait alors
week end pour la parole depuis tout à
l'heure je vais dire merci au lieu
guillaume bien sûr que le documentaire
ils étaient à charge et moi j'ai senti
un truc en regardant l'émission dé le
plateau début de bernard de la
villardière ils sont dégoûtés de pas
l'avoir eue dans le documentaire et 10
maintes et maintes fois on n'a pas
réussi à l'avoir on n'a pas réussi à
l'avoir
bon c'est comme ça oui c'est pourquoi
oui j'ai parti pour ça que ça a joué
ouais moi j'ai juste une question
pourquoi on l'a vu sur ces news sur bfm
je me pose la question vous allez 2,6 et
or on l'a vu toujours face à des
journalistes me dis qu'il ya un moyen de
se défendre parce que c'est du direct
est-ce que là c'est pas le fait que ce
soit un libérateur un documentaire on
peut monter la rue parce que c'est pas
un truc c'est qu'en fait par expérience
six mois il avait demandé pour le coup
je passe en conseillant comme messi
l'avait demandé j'aurais dit n'y allez
pas parce que de la villardière et ses
méthodes je les connais quand même hein
j'ai eu des clients déjà qu'ils sont
passés dans la religion sont plaints ces
parquets
alors vous voulez tout achat se trouvait
à charge évidemment mais ce que doit
dire surtout c'est qu'il ya un fanatisme
autour du professeur alors justement oui
justement mais c'est lui qui la clinique
elle fait ça parce qu'il est tellement
mégalo rappelez-vous toutes les
interviews qu'il a données
il est incroyable il envoie balader les
gens et l'encens et dont on a tendance à
croire quand on l'attaqué sur sa sur son
caractère son côté autoritaire etc
vous vous rendez vous bien d'eux me mois
un chiffre comme gilles à tout faire et
il a donné une designer à la combe
combien à karim la coupe un bras ou bien
on a fait une dizaine non mais c'est une
vraie question c'est à dire que vous
dites il a fait beaucoup d'idées
je m'étonne alors est ce que vous avez
en face à un jean qui étaient tous les
soirs je m'attendais un mec comme j'ai
eu 20 ans je sais pas comment il fait il
a le don d'ubiquité ce mec il est sûr
c'est giuseppe à faire en même temps
sauf que le professeur a on le disait ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est rien ça va se
terminer
il a dit autre chose aussi il a bien
d'autres choses édition prend en charge
les patients dans la phase précoce alors
c'est rien on n'a pas fait ce qu'il a
dit d'abord n'a pas dit c'est rien il a
dit effectivement on réussira à s'en
sortir
or on n'a pas pris en charge des
patients en phase précoce et on vient
dire regardez moi c'est un bruit non je
dis qu'effectivement tout cas ma vie et
que je note
non ce que je vous dis c'est que moi
j'ai quand même je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure un certain nombre de médecins et
non des moindres qui vous dis je
les mis en place et quand je les ai mis
en place ça a marché
oui très bien à l'équipe oui volet
rajoute un côté diyab un mois le vaccin
c'est de la science fiction
ça va rien changer là excusez moi en se
marrant le bac ça n'existe pas alors que
l'europe en avait commandé je crois 600
millions de doses
c'est un vrai que je dis ce que je dis
c'est que nous avons un certain alain
fischer qui quand même monsieur max je
veux pas que ça effectivement qu'ils
avaient plus ou moins dit la même chose
qu'avait dit j'avais dit début décembre
il avait dit oui alors je sais pas les
vaccins ainsi que des communiqués de
presse eric holmes qui a dit la même
chose qu'avait dit exactement
oui mais attendez moi pour l'instant je
connais communiqué de presse à moi les
vaccins n'a toujours pas vu mais vous
voyez il a dit c'est de la sorte et
aurélien alors dernière extrait les
chéris avant d'avoir notre témoin du
jour dans un instant ils ont été
à la ciotat où un magasin de bougies a
peut être sauvé de la faillite grâce a
dit regardez pas cette histoire avec la
belle de la femme du professeur ils ont
vendu les bougies à son effigie et ça
cartonne
j'y pense à l'intérieur aux côtés de
madonna de britney spears ou encore de
mick jagger trône en bonne place
didier rahout on n'avait plus d'argent
qu'ils rentraient par contre on en avait
qui sortait et du fait qu'on a fait
cette bougie on a eu des commandes sur
internet après la faillite
le couple en a déjà vendu pour plus de
20000 euros à marseille
didier roules tu est un véritable
phénomène de société
il a un savon à son image et plus
surprenant une collection de bière la
chloroquine dundee alors c'était les
spectateurs allaient chéri de petites
secondes oui à 72 en ont abattu pour
sortir de nicolas pernikoff entamé juste
un truc c'est un des cinq tours aux
chercheurs dans le monde
est ce que vous trouvez qui mérite qu'on
lui fasse une émission comme ça entre
autres on commence par des bougies en
disant que c'est un miracle apprend on
monte sa bague tête de mort
franchement je trouve que le
documentaire il est scandaleux c'est
honteux même à criminelle a cartonné
non mais attendez et vous savez pourquoi
ça a cartonné parce que ceux qui sont
nus c'est ceux qui croient au professeur
raoul temps c'est pour ça que c'est un
miracle
non c'est le meilleur score c'est le
meilleur accord depuis deux ans au
cameroun j'ai regardé en cache pas qu'au
bout de 20 minutes j'ai décroché parce
que j'ai trouvé ça scandaleux syrien
du bien au moral le professeur raoul
puisque mois de mars a promis à nous
dire et moi je disais maintenant il y
aura pas de coricancha un vaccin faut
huit ans il vient de confirmer face à
saran de mettre le masque et un vaccin
ses huit heures merci nous a fait du
bien quand même